this is the aha moment if you were born
with blue tinted glasses
nothing would look blue because that was
all you've ever known right
right right so that's the right so right
here
right here what we're up against is that
you don't blue that i don't know i have
on
yes yeah beautiful but that's why i want
you to feel it especially as a woman
because women are much more
um available to their own emotions and
feelings this if you could feel like you
said it
you said it perfectly i've abandoned
myself in the process of trying to
protect myself
it looks like i'm being more considerate
of the other person which is actually
about self-preservation
going back to the child that didn't want
to get in trouble didn't want to upset
mom whatever it is
and so actually you're abandoning your
own self
in the process of self-survival now once
you see
that there's got to be some feeling of
something not like there has to be like
i'm forcing it but when you really wake
up and go wow
i have truly because without going
through every item of your
romantic relationships and where there
was hostility or there was hardship or
there was
you know derogatory ex at your expense
you know there was abuse of some form
and abuse is a big word but like it
could be the way someone spoke to you
like that's the abandonment of yourself
so if you can
you know if you could collapse all of
these experiences
there's going to be something there
right
and what what i mean i get i think
you're right there's there's there's
some
sort of imaginary wall between these
existences of
of me being able to truly feel it's
maybe this is it i don't know um this is
the
process of healing
to be able to feel for the abandoned
child abandon inner self
yes the inner child yeah like if i'm if
that's
if being that way and i said it's a i
feel like that'd be abandoning
yeah what would it feel like to abandon
someone you're asking that
if i could create understand that
feeling if i could start to access that
feeling i would
now create the relationship with the
inner child
because that's exactly what i've done to
it yes
and it gets a little deeper because
you're also the inner child so there's
not only the experience of a woman
who is denying her own needs her own
worth the way that people treat her
which is the abandonment of self but
there's the experience of that which is
abandoned within you
meaning the little girl so the mother
that she adores that she doesn't know
what she's done wrong
to feel abandoned by she also has an
experience
yes one of the things that i've done in
the last year to
um bridge that gap a little bit because
it seems easier like oh
i can handle crap i can handle being
treated like [ __ ] i can handle
all the whatever emotional abuse or
anything that's gone on um
is to imagine the way that someone's
treating me would i ever let them treat
my little girl like that yeah
and i imagine that to be my inner child
yes and so i somewhat disassociate from
it even though i know it's me
yes it's easier to access the ability to
treat myself properly if i
imagine that it's a little girl in me
yes
of course and that's another protection
mechanism right so look at the words you
use like i can handle the emotional
abuse and whatever it is like
yeah and people might describe you as
like i know she's awesome she's tough
would probably be a word and you look at
your career
and the fact that you're competing
against guys and in a sport that is
you know all of the things right like
that speaks to somebody whose persona
has become
you know very robust but that doesn't
speak to what's beneath it
and that's what i'm like like picking
away at very gently here and you're
doing a great job and i know it's a
podcast but
like you know there is okay
so so i still want to come back to what
does it feel like
because you know there's a little bit of
like deflection here
when you recognize that you have
feelings right and i'm not talking in a
woo-woo kind of kumbaya
but you're a sentient being you're a
woman you know an
extraordinary woman and an accomplished
woman and a caring woman
and the degree to which all of that gets
kind of pushed to one side because you
can handle the abuse
as i tell people just because it's
familiar doesn't mean it's healthy right
totally yeah so so can you just
even if it's a word or two if you
recognize the degree to which you've
discarded
some of your own like care of self
what would that leave you feeling
to recognize well i have completely in
ways that is not like your fault but it
is your responsibility is the way i said
like it's an unconscious process it's
the blue tinted glasses you didn't know
so you don't have to feel shame or guilt
but once you see it and go wow i've
really disregarded my needs over and
over and over
like how does that hit you when you
really see it
like negligent like yeah
[Music]
abusive in the opposite way that i
express it yeah
right it's avoidant yeah it's
disassociative
yeah even though i express more on the
side of
codependency or or the anxious
attachment or the wanting or diving in
or
unpacking talking it's actually
inside of myself it feels like it
is the opposite side of the spectrum
which is the same hole
as we've kind of been expressing and it
would be like i've disassociated with
myself and so it feels
um that's why it's so hurtful because
that's exactly what i do to myself
there you go so there's a there's now
you've used a word that i want which is
it's hurtful
because all the words you're super
articulate but they're all they're a
little bit still from here up
right and i'm just wanting to get a
little bit closer to this thing which
you have a huge one on
but really that's the first glimpse
you've given me it's hurtful
like as much as you can say i can handle
the emotional abuse of whatever
boyfriend this
or a male dad or it doesn't even have to
be male but you get the point i'm sure
if i were a fly on the wall of your life
i would have witnessed a lot
that is hurtful but you've learned to
protect yourself and be okay with it
even though you're not actually okay
with it energetically
and physiologically it will manifest in
different ways over time you know you're
still young and healthy
but over time that's what becomes
dis-ease
you know manifest physiologically
because of the absence of ease in our
system because we're actually hurt
and hurts bedfellow is also fear scared
yeah so that little girl who's protected
herself by virtue of becoming tough and
resilient is actually
hurt and scared she's hurt from a past
event that was tough
and now she's scared of its repetition
so
hurt is great can you find like where
there might be the scared
and the fear the concern the anxiety the
apprehension
sad sad for sure
worthless yeah worthless is very you
know it's a it's an adult way of saying
like there's a feeling of like i'm not
special i'm not loved i'm not wanted
yeah yeah yeah but all of that belongs
to that little girl
yeah so you're doing awesome yeah um
unimportant
like you know kind of the somewhat of
the inner child work that i've done
uh associating with her um
is that she was like i'm gonna be really
descriptive it's gonna be
sounds pretty maybe weird to people yeah
um maybe not to you because you've
probably heard everything
but i imagine that this inner child the
little girl in me was like it was as if
she was like
sorry i have to close my eyes but it's
very visual for me um it's like
up in a tower like a dome and she was
inside of the dome and it was like a
concrete dome with like just a
tiny little hole to see the light and
there was no access there was like no
getting to it it was like you know
there's some childhood fictitious story
right about being up in the tower
yeah and then later on she came down and
it was as if she was at the bottom of
the tower now and she was like standing
at the doorway
um but still quiet always really quiet
no words
yeah because of like there it was almost
the feeling i got from it was that there
was no
it didn't matter anyway like there was
no point there was nobody was listening
right um and then it was as if she
finally got
taller and like stood next to me um
and then i had a recent experience where
i was
looking to talk to her as i talked to my
higher self my inner child
my soul whatever you want to call it
yeah um
and she has her name her name is lucy
and i went to go talk to her and she was
like
uh she i said i hadn't talked to you in
a while how you doing and
i know this probably sounds so weird to
people but then she was like that's okay
we're merging and i was like what and
then all of a sudden
she goes but you can talk to me anytime
you want just like this and then all of
a sudden this other
aspect somewhere else says this is
oneness
like true oneness is the embodiment of
your higher self or your soul or your
inner child or whatever you want to call
it
with the you so that you're totally
embodied in
in your in your life every day
how you live it what you say how you
feel yeah
anyway so that's been like the evolution
of
my inner child works over beautiful and
very powerful images right like you look
at some of the things like so height
like extended away from the ground like
you're separated
concrete is the word you use it's not
like it was a dome that was made of
linen
concrete so there's a level of
protection and isolation
and the second law of thermodynamics
speaks to any isolated object is by
virtue of the fact that it's isolated
you think of like in a
correction facility they put them in
solitary confinement that is the
ultimate form of isolation
and there is going to be this
deleterious effect over time you start
to lose your mind you
have no sense of belonging so this is
where the hurt is and where
you also gave a huge a tell when you
said you know and she came down and she
was
she didn't have anything to say she was
very quiet and you said because what's
the point no one's going to listen
anyway
that speaks to the dismissiveness that
she experienced right
and there's no value there there's no
sense of importance there's no sense of
love like i'm not
curious to hear what my child has to say
is the experience
right now you're starting to feel it and
this is like the mom that i spoke of at
the hawaii retreat where she wasn't
listening to her son
she was at least doing a quote better
job superimposing
her version of superiority or love to
upon him
but he still wasn't being gotten yours
was obviously very different where
as often the case children are to be
seen and not heard
so that you know i see a little bit of
water behind the eyes where you can see
perhaps now wow that little girl was
really just disregarded
it's one thing to not be loved it's
another thing to feel not wanted
very similar but they're very powerfully
different because not being loved is one
thing
not being wanted has got a form and an
energy of disregard it's removing
you can be there and not be loved but if
you're not wanted
then you actually feel displaced now
that's a different breath
right so there's something energetically
that just got released
so that i'm guessing is going to be part
of your experiences that at times that
little girl who i guarantee you is a
sweetheart
very shy very creative very sensitive
but felt the experience of not being
wanted is my guess
yeah this is actually like i mean again
it's super honest but
this has been actually i always thought
it was my dad that i was getting all the
problems from
but it's my mom yeah that's what i was
picking up on
i mean just in recent experiences of
like things that have gone on
and like oh no i'm going to cry onto you
yeah it's beautiful but it was like it's
okay this is beautiful
like i realized that this is the wound
like